So let's calculate
what 2/5 divided by 7/3
is, and I encourage
you to pause this video
and try to calculate
this on your own.
Well we just have to
remind ourselves that this
is going to be the exact
same thing as 2 over 5 times
the reciprocal of 7/3,
which is 3 over 7.
And then multiplying
two fractions
is pretty straightforward.
This is just going to
be equal to the product
of the numerators.
So 2 times 3 over the
product of the denominators,
over 5 times 7-- I'm trying to
keep the colors consistent--
which of course is going
to be equal to 2 times 3
is equal to 6.
And 5 times 7-- I'll do this
in a new color, let's see,
I haven't used this shade of
blue yet-- 5 times 7 of course
is equal to 35.
So this is equal to 6/35.